on a plaisanté mais là on va rentrer
dans le vif du sujet la question
existentielle notamment messieurs
mesdames
la question est la suivante est ce que
pour vous la taille compte la taille de
poids un docteur une émission
extrêmement sérieuse sur france 5 est
parti enquêter oui parce qu'on enquête
sur ce sujet auprès des françaises
notamment lorsqu'on évoque le sexe
masculin
il est souvent question de performance
est ce que la taille ça compte ça dépend
des personnages je pense qu'il pourra
norme c'est très important parce y est
voilà il ya tout un tabou autour des
arts pas trop maximum non plus aussi
rétro enfin voila voila je pense que
c'est tout petit bah oui oui on a
interrogé quand même les français
c'est pour ces messieurs 45 % des hommes
sont satisfaits de leur monture a choisi
le bon ça va moi tu es tranquille 65
cent estiment qu'elle n'a pas d'impact
sur les performances
67 % des françaises y accordent peu
d'importance et 20% ne s'y intéresse pas
du tout ça rassure thibault du coup
alors messieurs
tu veux dire ma question d'abord
caroline socialiste
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme ça
ne veulent pas qu'est ce que les
adversaires toi ou moi j'ai eu et j'ai
regardé et je vous répondrai franchement
faut c'est la question franchement les
gens alors je vous pose la question
franchement en tant que femme
il est ce que n'a pas y compte alors
très franchement oui la taille compte
mais parfois très j'aimerais je m'arrête
de mentir sur ce sujet sur le petit côté
voilà la petite fois que vous venez de
dire très hypocrite on s'en fie serait
pas un petit peu non on s'en ficherait
pas un petit peu la paille soit de mai
une bonne taille est quelqu'un qui ne
sait absolument pas y faire voilà oui
mais alors une très petite taille est
quelqu'un qui en plus ne sied pas
nécessairement moyenne et moyenne plus
on s'en sort d'accord on s'appelait
moyenne vous parce qu'un voyage c'est
pas moi qui les calculer la moyenne sans
juger c'est que c'est que on est 11e
donc la route est longue
alors oui on ya des conseillers de m 11e
d'europe 11e voilà de même dans l'une
d'elles alors je vais vous dire en fait
poser parce que puisque visiblement vous
cherchez le classement de ces messieurs
en europe nous sommes 11e avec 14 points
47 cm de moyenne les numéros un en
europe si vous voulez faire un petit
tour un petit voyage du congrès que ça
se passe avec vincent hongrie voilà les
origines vous êtes tombés d'accord
et sinon dans le monde dans le monde
dans le monde les numéros 1 c'est le
congo avec 17,4 euros
[Musique]
[Rires]
et absolument
[Applaudissements]
j'ai dit combatif suivi de l'équateur le
ghana la colombie et le venezuela est
alors en est pour les plus petits
malheureusement on va aller du côté de
la corée du sud du cambodge et de la
thaïlande des coréens mais sérieusement
j'aime et je vais vous poser à voulait
la question messieurs sérieusement oui
est-ce que non mais parce que
visiblement c'est pas un sou c'est enfin
caroline le dit c'est important excès
mais j'ai l'impression que c'est plus
une question de garçons et qu'en fait
vous passez votre temps à vous comparez
à regarder ses voisins c'est plus plus
important moins important pour vous
rassurer vous alors que ces dames nous
on n'est pas tellement
oui c'est toujours la bonne place
toujours la bonne place mais après vous
devez caroline soyons très honnête quand
vous avez rencontré votre votre ami
votre amoureux votre mari le premier
truc que vous avez dit c'est vous que
vous avez regardé sais c'est pas pourvu
qu'il en ait une grosse enfin excusez
moi non bah pardon mais encore une fois
je suis désolé mais celle isolé d'être
frères j'ai lettre au nom du passé la
première chose mais ça fait partie des
trois priorités chez montaigne
mais après on a fait avec les autres
mais l'argent la lune
[Rires]
par exemple après vous vous dites tout
de suite j'espère que parce que la vie
sexuelle face à l' hyper important oui
m'enfin c'est ce qui fait tenir un
trépan cm la vie sexuelle s'est avéré
mais pardonnez moi mais venez chiner
venez chez moi qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que discussions en privé
l'hypocrisie là vous la poussez un peu
mais non mais je vous assure que moi
quand j'ai rencontré mon compagnon
premier truc que je me suis dit c'est il
est drôle il me fait rire et intelligent
il est sympa vous avez eu beaucoup de
chance c'est que tout au long de votre
vie vous avez rencontré des gens qui
avaient un sexe de taille sympathique
oui j'ai rencontré des gens des gens
très sympathiques de les voir que le
début de match donc on ne sait pas si on
ne sait pas c'est le jour où on se rend
compte que là ce que vous vous êtes
tombé nez à nez avec en fin d année et
c'est ma venue des sections de jour là
et c'est ce joie et ça remonte en mai
c'est ce jour là qu accor cette question
je me suis dit je t'aime la pause je
répondrais vraiment la vérité d'accord
oui ça a une importe car au sans aucune
gêne schwein experts ce rôle là mais il
paraît qu'il vomit une petite
travailleuses qu'une grosse saignante
lagarde ça dans ta tête oui enfin bon
d'accord non mais y avait 1 via des
mensurations c'est que la taille d'un
penny ça doit être entre 9 cm 5 et
maximum 17 cm 5 avec une moyenne en sept
ans oui mais c'est ça après en fait ce
qui est important c'est la communication
ça veut dire il ya des femmes qui sont
aptes à recevoir des grand pénis
donc ces femmes là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais franchement ça c'était vraiment
le choix parce que ça dépend aussi de la
femme elle aussi bien pour toi là chaque
fois elles sont couverts voilà moi je me
suis refusé
thibault pour terminer enfin je sais
même pas si je termine avec vous je sais
pas oui on est en moi j'ai vécu dans les
vestiaires de foot vous savez donc
dédiée alors d'hélicoptères et ses
agents raconté mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ça oui oui que vous nous demandez à
la base nous les gens concernés ou
demandé c'était un problème
oui en effet depuis tout petit c'est
quand même le truc qui revient stress ou
donc j'ai donc c'est parce qu'on est
donc c'est un problème entre en a b c
c'est la base pour nous les garçons
c'est un c'est vraiment un témoignage de
la virilité et donc c'est génial dans
les vestiaires si on peut se taper un
mec en lui dit aulas le bras de fer quoi
d'accord très bien écoutez je vous
remercie infiniment je veux c'est est
extrêmement instructif nous ce que vous
en pensez la taille du pénis est elle
importante
oui ou non non à 56 % les hommes ont
répondu donc majoritairement